today on our show we have some fun we're
gonna watch the trailer for a roll and
rhymed all that and so much more today
I'm Batman I'm Batman
well the Batman Batman Kevin Smith mark
barnard me man we're back
welcome back back in the fat cave it's
like a homecoming it really is man last
time we were together it was live in
front of hundreds of people and stuff
which we put that up on the channel if
they didn't there was no video for it
but we built like little imagery for it
so anyway enough about that we're here
to talk about the trailer man some
trailers that we missed while we were
away for about a week we're gonna start
off by talking about one trailer in this
episode that trailer is as previously
teased rogue one as you can tell him a
little bit explaining everything right
now Marquis probably take it over for a
second it's a trailer for a movie that
we're gonna see in my eight months a
Star Wars story oh there we go that's a
Star Wars that was sweet I kind of like
that yeah you know what else I like
about but I like the title in general
but I like when they cut to the title at
the end of the trailer jumping right to
the back of the trailer they say I like
that
yeah we're story that's cool I hope they
do like Boba Fett Star Wars yes take a
nice little book in like a way to wrap
it around you know what I'm saying
that's because they used to remember it
used to be star and then words in the
middle was Empire Strikes Back or Return
of the Jedi so I buy that man do you
think we'll ever see Bea Arthur in the
cantina a story because if you expand
the universe you get your tendrils back
to the baby Blanche
okay so I liked what I liked at the end
of the trail I like the reuse of the
stars and and I didn't like the super
minor key and very like haunting yeah
nice pretty sweet we're bringing it down
a bit because we're dealing with crime
and villains and anti-heroes and Donnie
Yen kicking ass and Forest Whitaker The
Ghost Dog returns a that's fort now
Forest Whitaker correct me if I'm wrong
first major black male character in Star
Wars universe since Finn since then too
in the new universe the only universe
one guy up to because you had a Sam
Jackson well he's the second universe
well yeah well my technically the first
heavens yeah prequel trilogy had one
black guy
- shot for this you need to see our
faces as we get into race don't be
cutting around first so the prequel
trilogy 's have Sam Jackson one black
and there was the palace guard for I got
you princess and he was like let's use
our jump guns dude alright so but really
Sam Jackson yes
so the Star Wars trilogy yes the og
truth also has one black guy Lando
Calrissian so right now off the bat Finn
in force awakens and who's he playing
hold on we got a no we don't know but
also this is given the timeline of this
this slots between the the what would it
be if if is right so chronologically
chronologic it would be Sam Jackson
universe then forced would occur right
then Billy Dee was right so this is
between Revenge of the Sith and a new
hope yeah then this is this weird little
meta period and that's one of the things
I loved about this trailers then it
looks oh that was bad stormtroopers look
old you're on the you haven't base and
everything looks green classic chard
trooper structure was not like the
stormtroopers in the force awakens but
there's nice to see the classic
stormtroopers yeah everything matched
the Star Destroyers look white like as
opposed to they got more in Star Wars
they're very white yeah like white metal
they get more detail than grey as those
movies go on but here they kind of went
right back to the match man they got as
you see there are oyster vaporators in
the back because that's really what all
these Star Wars movies about that's at
the heart of it all how converters in
moisture VAT if you chase the money if
you follow the money money in the Star
Wars
is in moisture evaporates with a credit
our I think that's where the dude and
the white Imperial I think he's like
that's he's like my family came from
moisture evaporation money eight
generations back that is the dude from
God doesn't he look like magneto they're
totally he does right and Mendelsohn the
magneto man but Ben Mendelsohn is the
guy who's in the Netflix show bloodline
with Friday Night Lights himself oh
right that dude the coach Josh Taylor
great good whatever but anyway I mean
he's in it but Ben Mendelsohn said but
ben mendelsohn mostly known to our
people as the guy and Dark Knight
Returns that Bane is like are necessary
any jokes he's the guy that like
Catwoman puts his foot up too much in a
flunky the business funky gun business
guy who like promises like I could get
your name there at the clean slate clean
slate yeah the clean slate so now he's
in he's rockin Star Wars he's running a
serious cape but he's in another like
fandom universe oh I've got a foot in
the Dark Knight trilogy you got a foot
in the new Star Wars movies he's doing
good I don't mess smart he's like how in
her locker good dumb as a stump yeah
doing alright long as somebody's making
those calls but that's cool man he looks
badass man in the long like white outfit
and stuff can you ever remember white
Imperial soldiers in the extended
universe ER and the fanfic universe and
that she looks a bit like a muff if I
had to guess like he's got that sort of
like the guitar he was very wasn't well
that's sort of a grayish whitish thing
but that's sort of like the row of
imperial medals or in signals whatever
he looks like he belongs well he'll be
on the Death Star or unless they kill
him in this movie he's not a Schmo
I get the feel yeah he's a higher you
don't give a flying [ __ ] do you see him
alive you don't care he's like I got
nine of these I got Vatican force clean
this it's fewer life here truly but even
if you could have Vader force cleaner
like why would you waste his talents
like that but even if you had enough
money like even if you were [ __ ]
staggeringly rich would you later cape
like drag in the water
I mean I've heard tell of also the
staggering the rich people who don't
wear the same socks twice the [ __ ] out
here
yeah really yeah it's just a good Burnet
and you're not talking about like they
don't wear the same socks twice in a
week they never wear the same size ever
like tissues just like I don't need
these instead I can never be a rich man
I'll Rock the same underwear until I see
some bacon so I can sit them like a bomb
until I'm like this foul reused man
that's not green is it it's really Carol
[ __ ] eating green no we don't care
about the environment you blowing up
planets you're building the Death Star
it must have something to do with that
that was one of the things delightful to
see in the trailer some people online
reacted poorly they like a death star
again but it's like this is da da da
feat the one you love [ __ ] exactly
should have subtitled that the one you
like we get to see the fake fat disk
putting on like that's one of those
images like when they showed the image
in the force awakens trailer of the
downed Star Destroyer in the desert and
[ __ ] like that you're like wow that's a
resting and like I never would have
thought of that but I now it's in my
visual lexicon forever and I'll never
not see the beach without seeing a
[ __ ] down starter in or something
like that that has the power the same
kind of image right there that plants in
deep where you're like oh my god that's
what it looked like when they put that
very famous [ __ ] disc that I've seen
since 1977 in place we never got to see
it in place so it's kind of like iconic
man iconic imagery I give it up for a
Godzilla Godzilla voice yeah Gareth
Gareth whoa Gareth Edwards I think
carries British Irish Scottish want to
say he's not American no he's a place of
it's an ish he's an ish he [ __ ]
killed it man like I saw a lot of that
Godzilla some of it I was like but but
when he was on when they show you
Godzilla whenever it was not about the
Scarlet Witch and [ __ ] kick-ass
I was dialed
dial the [ __ ] in but that that is
awesome as Godzilla looked in those
moments like before the door closed when
there let them fight me that's why I
came out the fight and they closed like
a Kevin Smith version of Godzilla
he deserves all the [ __ ] monies and
all the praise if he's the guy that's
like what if we put the disc on the
front of the Death Star no people would
love to see a dance on the beach like
cake by the ocean but with a dance on
the beach absolutely he must have been
beside himself dude because he's like
well JJ got to put one hat on its side
and force awakens' remember race it
that's a dimension but but that was just
laying outside now I remember out
[ __ ] like ah my nipples got hard
seeing that force awakens but you're
right in this trailer they [ __ ] save
it to the end like is a true money shot
man cuz then by that point we're all
shooting [ __ ] show us a dat's on the
move man some of you have not seen since
the Empire Strikes Back really I mean
yeah you've seen in the cartoons and
probably rebels did it I'm sure
something like that but this is like the
first in action at at [ __ ] I've seen I
think since the Empire me yeah and it's
like you at ground level yeah that's
what I loved about it I mean as much as
I love being at Empire you're flying
you're with Luke and you're and you're
in the snowspeeder and it's great but
here you're down here looking up it's
[ __ ] staggering yeah and I'm a
director so I should have made that
point about like you had a perspective
instead I was just like big marks like
yes but poetically were beautifully
visual yes good point seeing that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] fantastic man like yeah or
that they could put an ad out in every
not not just all these Star Wars movies
but a few other movies as well I would
like to see my dad on blackish oh my god
just dropping down the street like
somebody [ __ ] got it on you know
Craigslist and then you take it from
there either
it's ABC you should have liked that week
where there's a man that just makes its
way through every first blockage on ABC
and ABC is owned by Disney star wars is
owned by Disney
synergy folks make it happen come on
there's a smart [ __ ] guy right there
isn't able higher let's try to get him
away from the LA Times just try do your
best please yeah bit hanger [ __ ] we see
the hanger for fun don't blink man we've
seen the Yavin hanger look at that [ __ ]
and look at them in their [ __ ]
outfits outfits from Star Wars do the
goddamn rebel soldiers and those are
rebel fighters that's a rebel x-wing
pilot that is not a resistance fighter
no as the code Ameren was and I got none
against that that's cool but this is
old-school son
and it's an old-school x-wing this is
one you and me were children and [ __ ]
this is the wonderful part about all
this look at there's a power droid you
see dude the box
I had three figures of power choice
because to my friends through theirs out
and the sticker came off a chosing all
too good okay regarded so I had three I
could have recreated that [ __ ] scene
could have called me instead they went
Godzilla boy that Godzilla boy I said
before I'll say it again deserves well I
didn't said it he deserves all the
[ __ ] because that [ __ ] movie
looks amazing dude you have to follow
force awakens which in and of itself was
an amazing [ __ ] balancing act high
wire act of a reboot of a sequel to one
of the most beloved franchises of all
time and he [ __ ] did it like you
nailed it it is crazy how [ __ ] well
he did it so anyone else following like
he's already blazed the trail and [ __ ]
next person following had the tall order
of like I gotta follow JJ that's like
following [ __ ] Liam Neeson like into
bed not not in a bed like move over Liam
but like if he was to [ __ ] someone in
you go next your hot dog in the hallway
man he has a very particular set of
skills
we run closer but imagine man this guy
steps up to the plate with the trailer
and they didn't make a big deal I mean
they did announce one day in advance to
like rogue one teaser coming on tomorrow
and we're like what what but this they
stepped up to plate man this guy's got a
[ __ ] legit movie that when you look
at the trailer like wow man like it was
Jay Jay involved and I didn't know what
I was gonna get but I know that I want
more of it you know it's like when they
announced this movie I was like I I
guess that's cute like look I'll see
[ __ ] star was anything even if it was
like we kill Kev's mother a Star Wars
story I'd be like well mom I'm sorry but
like I've been a fan forever but I you
know I'm on board but I wasn't like man
I can't [ __ ] wait then I saw this
[ __ ] and then I was like being in pain
like this house looks great what do I
know her friend she was in a few of
everything with boy won an Oscar yes
beasts right hey that's it Eddie
Redmayne the guy who is then that
[ __ ] Jupiter rising movement you
unfortunately if any talk low and then
he screamed a lot yeah man she's
fantastic I saw Ralph put a tweet up on
Twitter where he said Disney is like
holding all the British actresses with
slight overbites because her the girl
plays ray Daisy Ridley and then also I
guess it was the one from was that show
that he's on from time to time agent
Carter
oh hell yeah well could I guess she
apparently Disney's got a thing for
British brunettes I mean I thought she
was dynamite in the trail I must have
seen her something else cuz she looks
familiar
I mean she does a real like girl next
door kind of like that did I go to
school with her kind of look but did you
shave me down for everything she was
like just the one line dude which is
like such a movie line but I [ __ ]
loved it where you know it isn't this a
rebellion I rebelled oh that was awesome
I was glad and then it ends with her in
the suit what he that's the down
yeah so what a TIE fighter black-tie a
TIE fighter pilot what do you think is
that her escaping like they're trying to
make it seem like who's such young but I
don't think she [ __ ] cereal dude what
if what if hold on we got go do it a
single because he's writing what what if
she plays the the TIE fighter pilot was
one of Vader's escorts that knocks Vader
off cuz that's that's the scene right go
to the [ __ ] signal quick when han
Solo you hit my signal my signal you can
literally [ __ ] sing goose bumps and my
eyes glassed over now go to a two-shot
yeah I [ __ ] I hope that's it cuz that
is [ __ ] brilliant I'm not about to
cry so good oh my god that would rewrite
history dude and as much as it wasn't
like I mean Han Solo still streaks out
of the sky oh shoot she's like yeah and
she sacrifices herself to save Luke
Skywalker so he can blow up the Death
Star I'm done I mean [ __ ] do that
somebody call them and do that JJ look I
don't know if you did this because
[ __ ] joke um so wow you want even
further than I do because I'm like
Watson Star Wars but this has to it's
got a dovetail at some point into the so
you think you can see my in my head I'm
such a bad [ __ ] right all those
critics are right dude like I'm really
starting to realize like I'm an idiot
and real [ __ ] straightforward but in
my mind I'm like well the movie has to
stop once they stick the plans about you
because that would make sense but what
you said is [ __ ] don't because then
they can they can stick the plans in
r2d2 like with 20 minutes left and then
do cuz we all know what's coming
yeah they don't have to end with like I
wonder what will happen they could
literally [ __ ] jack into the like
last 20 minutes of [ __ ] stars because
these movies are kind of parallel aren't
that yeah I mean at least at that point
they sort of join at that point yeah I
mean while he is she's they show us the
Aven base they show us preparations yeah
so this is a story that's happening in
tandem too
stores so you can have that amazing
scene when Luke gets out and Kari runs
over and then in the corner you have
those eight guys who did that heist
mourning her death because she died you
[ __ ] bastard just like the sad
mournful funeral for a person that
nobody else knows Luke Skywalker has no
idea what this girl's name is Han Solo
doesn't know that somebody actually did
his job for him why is he wasting his
time that is gold dude go all of the
tears if they do that all the [ __ ] to
you all the tears oh my god absolutely
just lay in that footage from [ __ ] a
new hope just in the distance oh you got
me man how you got my [ __ ] wet mop
say what they could also do is like you
you can [ __ ] show the awards ceremony
and you could cut off to the side where
like somebody get like look you can't be
on the stage case what you say is wrong
but you desert and then they get a medal
and that was the medal that Chewie was
supposed to get and that's what I do we
don't get a medal oh my god this amazing
dog doesn't get to win this but we
finally know why yeah like after [ __ ]
30 how many years ago that come out 30
years yeah 30 after 30 years of
wondering why did they give Chewie a
medal at the end now we know now we know
it was like because they gave it to
somebody who [ __ ] mattered the last
thing we got to talk about dude is a big
thing because it ties into the other
movies and [ __ ] and I had no idea that I
would be this excited by the appearance
of middle to older age woman in a robe
and a flowing well not since like you
know seeing my mom when I come off the
plane after not seeing her for months
have I been that happy to see a woman
was short hair
and Christ's head oh my god
it's mon mothma kids one of the easiest
punchlines in Star Wars humor history
man is to just throw in a rock him with
a Mon Mothma there she is from Return of
the Jedi
that's the original mama yes now show
the new style new new new styles Mon
Mothma
jacket can you tell the difference I
can't believe that's not butter looks
like her did so much show that when I
was watching the trailer I was like oh
my god they went back and recreated the
footage Endor found her did they clone
th her or something and somebody was
like they just found some mister sure
dere and put the same money a Brit who
looks just like this what you feel like
you do know that they change Batman's
quite a bit to don't know what
but yeah mom Mothma dude back like a
[ __ ] and who knew that that
would be an exciting thing like I'm
excited like the idea of anything tying
in to those movies but wait a sec well
she went at Star Wars though right her
first introduction is in Return of the
Jedi if I remember correctly that's what
she's like many Bothans yeah died to
bring his his information he remembers
yes um so she wasn't in Star Wars but
this now places her squarely into the
rebellion I mean she would have been I
mean she would have been in the
rebellion you don't get to be like
general Mon Mothma and show up like
three days before can I join sure and
again Akbar is like I have a buddy
well me mom mom mom yeah then again Han
Solo's a general by Jedi it's like that
[ __ ] was a criminal too movies
oh girl was easy listening he may have
been a general Empire they call him
general solo yeah the pop bases do there
was a commander solo something he rises
it relatively quickly through the ranks
why am i arguing with like you've
already [ __ ] spat out like genius god
damn it dude I hope that's it and if it
said he's a [ __ ] brilliant genius
like also a fortune teller
stealing all of your money look at that
[ __ ] unbelievable man like tell me like
what am I thinking right
we our son division at the Voodoo mom
moth masback kids and that's a reason to
celebrate
it's cuz mom Martha was always the thing
you could whip it people like there's
only one woman in the Star Wars movies
are good oh no don't forget my mother
yes and she is like as equally as
powerful if not more so then Princess
Leia like now they could sort all this
out you know like now that are making
these extended universe movies and [ __ ]
like she's a princess Alderaan gets
destroyed
isn't she a queen at that point you'd
think so what happened there and also
this is a world where like her her mom
was Queen and then a senator but a
royalty was a paramedic
yeah in space parliamentary hereditary
royalty it's all kind of fluid kinda
strange like gender but now they can
explain that [ __ ] yes maybe now like you
know because this when she when Princess
Leia is stick in the plans into r2
mm-hmm she is on a diplomatic mission if
this is a diplomatic visit that was so
she's not a memo a part of the rebellion
yet no she's still in the Galactic
Senate so my so by the end of Star Wars
like [ __ ] cards on the table they're
like this [ __ ] she's part of the
goddamn rebellion right and also how
does she get to be princess but her
father is just like a senator like Bail
Organa is not King Organa right yeah
he's just like a politician guy and
she's a princess whole thing [ __ ]
whole [ __ ] big falls apart but you
know what you know it's gonna sell it
right back up
rogue one bring it this [ __ ] movie
looks amazing hats off to the Godzilla
boy what's his doctor god Suki who
brought it home for us this [ __ ] guy
Suki kid he's got the world by the balls
dude and he can have all my money
because I there's almost nothing I want
to see as much as this man and I did
no I wasn't ready for this this is a new
holiday there what he told me is that
account you know what this is like this
is [ __ ] scary because this is like
being married
we're both married and all of a sudden
you meet someone has swept you off your
feet like you and where the bread where
you're ready to destroy you watch the
[ __ ] TV movies about this all the
time where you're ready to throw
everything away for this person you just
met that's how I feel about this rogue
one trailer
I've leave my wife or no I don't mean
that but I'm ready to let go of any
movie I was holding on to and embrace
this this is the strange yeah that's
true in fact there are two more trailers
and we're going to talk about this you
know yeah strange yeah yeah come back
next week man you can see the strain we
get on the strange you into the strange
you love the strange yeah we will give
you the strange well we're talking about
it
balls deep in the strange visual on our
next episode that's for sure so for fat
man about knob and Kevin Smith mark
barnard and come back next week same fat
time same board next episode rather
don't waste on Mexico man keep coming
keep coming to a strange same fat time
saying fat channel smart up you DC you
do this mathcast not calm and I'll do
that you punk ass time comments or you
do that calm / Kevin Smith sees always a
better writer don't remember
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder